in the near term absolutely i mean what
we have seen just this year you know
certainly has been a significant
decrease in terms of recruiting activity
on campus from the from the financial
community we were reasonably diversified
going into this about 20 somewhat less
between twenty and twenty-five percent
of our students our mba students were
going into we're going into finance so
we had less repositioning to do than
some of those 50-plus schools that that
you'd be mentioning a moment ago but
definitely we have seen a repositioning
and you know many more of our students
are interested in now going into a
really quite varied set of set of
positions consumer packaged goods is
pretty strong health care is obviously
growing technology oriented things so so
we're a general management school and
our orientation to a general management
and action based learning has meant that
we historically have been less orient
toward finance but i suspect even for us
being a general management school the
placement of our students in the finance
world i would we fully anticipate that
that will be a small percentage this
year than it has been in the recent past
well I don't know that we have to incent
them so much is that the market will
incentive and set them to it I you know
I never I never wearing too much about
us incenting students one direction or
another I think our responsibility was
to educate students make them be
thoughtful about their career choice and
then while some schools would look at
their fifty percent of students going
into finance and be horrified at that
number of so many going into industries
in which you don't quote make things I
always felt our job was to really
provide a great general management
experience for our students and then if
they chose to go into one industry
another that that was really their
choice so so I don't think it's so much
that the company that the schools have
to now in sent their students to go
elsewhere it's just that there's always
going to be financial activity but just
not at the scale that we've seen and so
as the salaries maybe come down a little
bit in finance there won't be the strong
economic incentive to go and obviously
just if the jobs aren't there in finance
the students are going to be preparing
themselves I think to to have a little
broader set of of options when they
graduate
not in my judgment I think I think
business schools have really taken to
take taken the responsibility of
developing some ethical education into
into the curriculum in a really
substantive way schools have taken that
extremely seriously and if you look at
what's been done over the last 20 years
or so I think the schools have done a
great job you know the the problem to me
with the certification it's almost like
well if we can check off the box then we
can forget about it it was almost like
in the old days when everybody had to
have a special little set of ethics and
law courses that typically were required
and as long as the students took one or
two they were fine and the ethical
dimensions were not as then as present
in the everyday conversation of the
school and I think what we've tried to
do with Ross School of Business and I
know my colleagues at a number of the
other leading business schools have
really tried to do the same thing is to
take ethics and sustainability and those
kind of issues to take them not as
special topics which you cover in
orientation and then say oh okay that's
covered now we can get on to the real
stuff of marketing but you have to embed
the ethical discussions into the
everyday life for the school and I think
you have to create a responsibility for
doing that as well so so i weary a
little bit about whether some kind of
certification program or passing a test
would lead us more back to the old days
of saying everybody saying okay we have
these few courses and and we can check
them off and it really got to get the
substantive focus distracted from
because everybody's wearing about
showing that ninety-nine point nine
percent of their students passed some
certification test so so I think this is
a dimension on which I know business
schools are frequently criticized at the
moment but if people really understood
what is happening in the curriculum at
school and also I think in the wonderful
you know the wonderful students that we
and a number of the other
rules enjoy these days these students
really going to insist that ethics and
sustainability be part of the everyday
discussion of the school so so I really
feel pretty good about where we are on
that
there's probably three different three
different ways that that we would be
doing it what one would be we have
established a few years ago the Ross
Leadership Initiative which which one of
the sochi of Dean's run runs for us and
so that is an integrated package of
material that that we use to bring up
issues of social responsibility and
business ethics so so I think one of the
important elements of our training is
during your first week at school during
the orientation program we spend one day
on community service and so we all go
out and do a community service project
that we all come back together all 450
of us or so and discuss about well what
did we learn that day and what's the
meaning of this kind of activity so I
think from very early on what we're
trying to do is get these issues of
corporate social responsibility into the
into the minds of students and then our
net impact Club which is I think the
largest chapter in the United States you
know which Foster's the triple bottom
line kind of philosophy of social
responsibility ethical responsibility
and and profitability as three different
important measures to be bringing into
discussion that kind of thinking is
embodied in our in our everyday in our
everyday classes and so so I think those
are two important ways then the third
one would just be what we do in terms of
bringing in outside speakers and through
our club activities like we have the
global corporate responsibility group so
i think it's the way that we try to as i
was saying a moment ago really have it
be part of the everyday everyday life of
the school
well I think the you know I think the it
would be a good idea to to tie bonuses
to to specific performance goals I think
and that's something which seemingly has
gotten lost that that the bonuses while
people always call them bonuses they
really in fact in many industries had
become more or less an entitlement where
there wasn't a tie of well we'll get
this kind of bonus assuming assuming
these kind of performance metrics so I
think incentive pay in general is not a
bad idea and certainly they've been lots
of industries which have done much
better because they tied the they
aligned the financial performance of the
firm with the with the financial rewards
to the employee so the idea of incentive
pay I think I think it's terrific but
you just have to make sure that there
are metrics that drive the profitability
of the firm that those metrics are the
same ones that the employees of being
incented to